algum tempo atrás duas primeiras aulas
que estava dando do semestre é como de
costume ele tem o direito de sempre
pergunta que os alunos sonho o objetivo
que eles têm
depois de formado ele ser advogados
juízes promotores e nessa conversa o
aluno levantou a taça na mão um aluno lá
no fundo foi uma pessoa
o passado o promotor impossível só gênio
passa promotor
isso aí é pra gente não é gênio ele a
pessoa só passou por promotores em gênio
é gênio
reprovei em quase 30 com o sul no início
da minha preparação para o concurso
público
até minha posse com o promotor de x eu
levei quase nove anos assumiu seu
primeiro cargo público eu demorei quase
cinco anos desde que eu comecei a
estudar para concurso
levei quase 10 reprovações até assumir o
primeiro nível médio
o conselho nacional de justiça vem falar
de seu gênio
e como ele gostava na verdade gosta
ainda de basquete
eu falei pra ele conhece michael jonas
ele é a pessoa mais jovem gênio o senhor
pelo que eu vi não tinha que vir do do
fundo da sala
e aí o michael jordan pois ele errou
diversas as 9 mil ha e mesmo perdeu mais
de 300 jogos ficou responsável pela uti
no último arremesso aquele decisiva na
vitória da derrota e com 25 26 vezes
falhou falhou várias outras vezes e é
por isso que ele é um sucesso e eu me
lembro também muito bem nessa fase de
concurso de certa forma até hoje na
minha primeira experiência em concurso
público não estava num segundo semestre
da faculdade lá no início de 2004 ainda
lutava essa febre de concurso público e
não é o estudante não era um estudioso
aluno longe de ser dedicado de ter boas
notas
era o que a gente chamaria devagar o é
desde o ensino médio e até o início em
meados da faculdade não era um aluno
exemplar
longe disso e nesse segundo semestre
estava ele com um grande amigo meu
rafael e ele comentou comigo foi o time
era negócio agora é concurso público
eu estava completamente fora do direito
não sabia de nada e que concurso público
a gente faz uma prova passa ganha
dinheiro trabalha pouco e ninguém manda
embora
é interessante isso aí especialmente
naquela época não se falava muito
negócio tenho meu estilo e como é que é
isso aí ele não daqui é o 34 meses ante
12 concursos marcados numa semana e
outro na semana seguinte um para a ntt e
outro panthaki o primeiro passo é
descobrir que era isso
depois vim a saber que a agência
nacional de transportes aquaviários e de
transporte terrestre agência reguladora
do governo federal estudava ó nunca foi
muito estudioso estudava na véspera das
provas conseguia passar com uma nota
razoável se estudar um mês dois meses eu
faço qualquer concurso
ninguém segura e eu e ele passou a
estudar horas e horas na biblioteca da
faculdade
nesses três meses horas a fio passarmos
- ano resolvendo a questão e chegou o
dia da prova
lembro direitinho a faculdade lá em
brasília nesta natal
eu entrei lá né cabeça erguida confiante
falei onde é que eu assumi a posse já
começa a trabalhar çom formada
eu simplesmente começar a trabalhar e
uma surpresa de quando eu recebi foi
dada attack
para receber a primeira prova da no
ataque
várias questões objetivas que o
absolutamente desconhecido outras que
não sabia
na verdade eu pensava que eu sabia que
não tinha segurança de marcar
alternativa correta e hora e na redação
o tema não fazia a mínima noção onde por
onde a gente quer começar a sair de lá
frustrado desanimado mas pensei não foi
um dia só o problema foi da prova não
foi legal né
semana que vem é meu dia e voltei cabeça
erguida confiante era na mesma faculdade
inclusive de novo ainda pior na segunda
vez
saí de lá absolutamente frustrado
desanimado
conversei com ele também também não
tinha ido bem não tinha ido bem na prova
na verdade tinha ido mal também não
desanimar vou conversar com o professor
de cursinho gente tinha um professor o
antigo lá em brasília
o pessoal vai acreditar que está
acontecendo tudo em quatro meses e não
passei
não fiz nem o mínimo necessário para a
prova de redação será corrigido
não sei se é bom ou ruim essa prova foi
corrigido de redação
mas nem o mínimo fiz ele riu
assim seus longos anos de prática
docente na área de concurso público da
história
no interior da china na zona rural
uma criança foi passar umas férias na
casa do avô e naquela época choveu
bastante dias e dias de chuva frio o
vento que o cascavel de vez em quando
e ao final dessa semana de frio chuva e
vento abrir um sol radiante o céu azul
eo menino abriu a janela do quarto
ele ficava e se surpreendeu quando viu
uma árvore ele jogava em quebrável de
tronco extremamente grosso firme galhos
imensos resistentes parte do homem e
para mais surpresas ainda dele
ele olhou para o lado e viu os bombos
além da casa do avô
de pé todos eles lançando ainda com
vento mais finos e qualquer ingenuidade
e curiosidade que as crianças têm e que
às vezes a gente perde ao longo da
amadurecimento chamou a vovó e vovô
nem penso aqui comigo olha só aquela
árvore filho de tronco grosso que a
gente não conseguia mexer em nada
a partida no meio eo bambu que eu
sozinho eo primo conseguimos mexer quase
derrubar segue filhos
o avô muitos anos além de experiência de
vida
no momento o bambu teve a humildade de
se envergonhar se curvar esperando
aquele momento adverso passar o bambu
tentou enfrentar aquela situação difícil
pela tempestade firme e simplesmente se
abaixou se curvou respeitou esperou o
momento certo para se reunir novamente
vamos ter flexibilidade e flexibilidade
o que a gente precisa um concurso
público na gestão na área da docência
quantas vezes ainda na área do concurso
se prepara para uma prova da rodada
maneira e de repente o cespe no antigo
sesp te pega no contrapé
o fcc coloca uma questão complicada uma
redação que você não espera
e você tem que ter flexibilidade para
resolver tudo
quantas vezes na gestão se prepara e
vislumbra qualquer possibilidade de
risco e de repente o mercado de
surpreende
uma decisão governamental você tem
perspectiva de idade para se adaptar e
esperar o momento certo para righi assim
como bambu além disso alguém aqui já viu
um bambu sozinho bambu sempre está
rodeado de outros bons bambu coopera com
outros a que outros da sua própria
natureza cresçam também
ele não se isola ele não impede o
crescimento dos outros
ele cresce junto opera em conjunto
isso a gente deve ter na nossa língua
no concurso público também tem um grupo
de amigos inclusive disse rafael que
ajudou durante o tempo todo em que no
momento de falha de fraqueza de derrota
eles me rendi em um momento de fraqueza
deles derrota eu os ajudaram e nós
quatro grupos de quatro
juntos estudamos hora a hora adentro
fazer exercício desafiando um outro
crescemos 1
hoje todos ocupam cargos de editar e
assim deve ser qualquer um segundo
cooperar e crescer diante tal como o
globo
o que torna os bandos os portes além da
criatividade e flexibilidade são os nós
eles têm dentro daquela estrutura oca
o que segura a firmeza dele
a resistência são os nós
aquelas experiências negativas nós
encaramos as dificuldades que a gente
tem as várias reprovações balançarmos de
seguirmos
são essas experiências difíceis nos
fazem crescer quando a vida nos derrubar
nos colocar no chão temos olhar pra cima
e ficar de costas no chão
a gente consegue olhar do alto a gente
consegue se levantar dificuldades
apareceram
e se eu tivesse desistido no primeiro
concurso anpac antt não sei onde estaria
hoje mas certamente não estaria aqui
tenhamos essa resistência a partir das
experiências negativas que a gente viu é
ali que a gente cresça
tal como bambu eo bambu só cresce pelo
alto
ele não se preocupa em alargar a sua
área de sombra em produzir frutos
ele tem um objetivo auto rumo ao céu e
não se desvirtue ele tem foco
e nós temos que ter foco em qualquer
área que a gente tem na área do concurso
público não adianta você tentar fazer
todos ou se vai demorar muito para
passar uns e não vai passar
não tem como a gente numa vida nessa
experiência pela infinita tentar sermos
bons em absolutamente tudo dá não dá pra
ser nível sucesso e todas as áreas e tem
que escolher uma ou mais dolorida que
seja a rejeitar as outras
temos que ter foco era uma frase do
livro dogma dina ele diz muitas pessoas
não descobrem o potencial que têm por
que se distraem com atividades
secundárias
nós precisamos ter foco do contrário a
gente não chega aonde a gente poderia
alguém já viu uma árvore crescer metade
do que ela pode produzir um texto dos
frutos que ela pode produzir aprofundar
as raízes menos do que ela consegue abri
a crescer o máximo que ela puder
produzir o máximo de frutos que ela
conseguir e aprofundar as raízes até
onde for possível e porque nós seres
humanos nos contentamos e ficar na
metade do que a gente pode não atingir o
nosso máximo profissional pessoal e
social afetiva espiritualmente
tivemos mesmo no mesmo dia tenhamos como
bambu foi o alto
além do foco do alto ele crava raízes
profundos
a firmeza do bambu
embora pareça que se pareça inseguro
a firmeza dele está nas raízes profundas
nós não podemos nos desviar do ar no
nosso caminho
nós precisamos de raízes profundas para
que tenhamos nosso caminho reto o alto
sem valores sem princípios e sem
atitudes firmes qualquer situação da
vida pode desvirtuar o nosso caminho
passamos como bambu cravando raízes
valores estáveis para nos conduzir essa
complexidade que a vida atual
no bambu
bush nem especialmente nos quatro
primeiros anos ele fica um pouquinho
um garoto que pouco cresce além do solo
chegamos desenvolvemos e ele
praticamente fica parado
parece até aqui não vai ter sim
enquanto que a gente não vê o cima da
terra a uma construção por debaixo
absurdo
enquanto ele não cresce ele aprofunda as
suas raízes ele fixa seus princípios
ele expande suas bases daí no quinto ano
como passe de mágica
ele subiu 25 30 metros de altura e nós
podemos pensar ah ah ele cresceu 25
metros em um ano
ele cresceu com os outros quatro
quando nós olhamos esportistas bem
sucedidos atores artistas no palco
ganhador de piadas jogando e aparecendo
em grandes times
a gente não faz idéia do tanto que eles
trabalharam a portas fechadas sem
ninguém olhando
lembro um se fosse ontem na entrevista
lutadora de tae kwon do brasileiro na
final do pan americano do rio o estádio
lotado e perguntou a ela um repórter
a taxa dessa dificuldade aqui de estar
com o estádio lotado todo mundo te
olhando tite observando a torcida
inteira torcendo pra você e todo mundo
acompanhando a mídia brasileira alan
dificuldade que é fácil o difícil foi
passar anos e anos treinando de
madrugada só eu e meu treinador
difícil é quando não tem nenhuma mídia
pouco apoio do patrocinador
nenhuma torcida e voltou a repetir o
mesmo golpe retidos e repetidas inúmeras
vezes ali é difícil lutar com todo mundo
torcendo pra mim
a sefaz e como diz o tony hobbies pipou
ordem público formado de prats foyers
inclusive não poderia ser mais verdade
eo bambu e ilustra isso com poucas áreas
não tenhamos a flexibilidade para deixar
situações complicadas mas a esperar o
momento certo de sorín
temos cooperação para trabalhar com
outros para que eles cresçam também
resiliência para enfrentar as
dificuldades
o foco não perdemos nosso um valores no
segundo nos segurar o nome certo armas e
paciência com paciência e todos esses
valores
a gente chega sem dúvida nenhuma um
sucesso
obrigado
[Aplausos]